like here's something counterintuitive i  think hope  is kind of a trap  um  if you remember the old pandora's box  story uh pandora in greek mythology she  opens this box and there's all these  horrible things in the box that come out  of the box war pestilence death famine  etc and uh  and she loses all these evils in the  world  and then at the bottom is hope and  that's supposed to make us feel good  like oh okay don't worry there's hope  that might actually be the biggest  problem  because hope is  you basically thinking things can be  better tomorrow and so not really  embracing what you have today and you  know if you're in a very difficult  situation maybe you need hope but i  think in general it's bad to live a life  full of hope because it's throwing today  away so um  i don't know how that question came up  but on the hope issue i i don't think  hope is necessarily a good thing it's  it's too much living in the future  [Music]  you